we all know Hollywood loves to recycle
ideas in fact while we don't often
realize that Studios sometimes even
reuse footage from old installments in
the same franchise or from completely
unrelated movies let's take a look back
at some of the most surprising examples
of filmmakers recycling parts from
another movie life and spider-man 3 the
idea of using stock footage in multiple
movies is nothing new but we received an
unexpected reminder of that when someone
discovered that a scene in a TV spot for
the 2017 sci-fi film life is actually
taken straight out of Sam Raimi's
spider-man 3 the scene in question
appears about 34 minutes into spider-man
3 with people looking up at Gwen Stacy
hanging off the edge of a building
shortly before spider-man comes and
rescues her
a slightly altered version of the scene
appeared around the 26 second mark in a
TV spot for life though it didn't make
it into the final cut
it's just b-roll footage used for the
commercial it's no coincidence that the
footage came from Columbia Pictures
since they're the studio that produced
and distributed both spider-man 3 and
life considering that venom was one of
the villains in spider-man 3 fans of the
superhero franchise have begun to
speculate a possible connection between
the two films what if the organism and
life is actually the Venom symbiote
that's a twist worthy of M night
Shyamalan Transformers Dark of the Moon
and the island recycling doesn't bother
Michael Bay he's guilty of reusing
several scenes from some of his older
films and often does it so seamlessly
that it's difficult to tell one of the
more recent examples can be spotted in
Transformers Dark of the Moon the third
Transformers movie features a car chase
scene on a freeway which includes a
portion of another car chase sequence
Bay had previously filmed for his 2005
release the island instead of having
bounty hunters chasing the good guys
though they replaced them with
Decepticons the inclusion of the island
sequence may have been due to the studio
wanting to limit liability the dark of
the moon set was particularly
accident-prone
the first major accident due to a
snapped steel cable left an extra
permanently brain damaged and partially
paralyzed a second accident occurred a
month later when the Camaro that
portrays bumblebee collided with a
police SUV injuring both drivers at that
point someone may have gotten the bright
idea to just use a car chase from
another movie transformers and Pearl
Harbor throwing 150 million dollars into
a summer blockbuster movie based on a
toy line would have been enough to put
any studio on edge so it's
understandable that when Michael Bay was
filming the original transformers he cut
corners by reusing a piece of footage of
an aircraft carrier from Pearl Harbor
while making harbor in 2000 they used
the USS Lexington to represent the USS
Hornet as well as a Japanese carrier
instead of shooting another scene using
one of the Navy's carriers for
transformers they just recycled his old
footage definitely cheaper than
arranging a whole new shot Austin Powers
The Spy Who shagged me and Apollo 13
when one movie uses footage from another
they're usually similar in
some way but there's nothing even
remotely alike between Austin Powers The
Spy Who shagged me and Apollo 13 these
two films ordinarily wouldn't find their
titles uttered in the same sentence were
it not for one particular scene in
Austin Powers mini-me escapes with dr.
evil to his moon base at the end of the
movie to capture him Austin and Felicity
hitch a ride on Apollo 11 along with one
of NASA's astronauts and if the whole
sequence seems out of place that's
because it is an eagle-eyed viewer
notice that it was taken right out of
Apollo 13 it was a sequence created by
Academy award-winning visual effects
designer Robert legato who received an
Oscar nomination for his work rogue one
and a new hope in some cases filmmakers
are upfront about reusing old footage as
was the case with Lucas films first Star
Wars anthology film in the original Star
Wars the Rebel Alliance destroyed the
Death Star after obtaining the Space
Station's blueprints and discovering its
fatal design flaw in open exhaust port
the reason for the vulnerable opening as
well as the way the rebels obtained the
Death Star plans in the first place
became the basis for rogue one rogue 1
story unfolds days before the events of
a new hope and ends mere moments before
the original film begins to give the
impression that the film is a prequel to
Episode four director Gareth Edwards
worked with ILM to digitally recreate
Peter Cushing and Carrie Fisher's
likenesses but they didn't stop there
the filmmakers also brought back the
original golden-red leaders played by
Angus McGuinness and drew Hindley
respectively Edwards was offered access
to the Lucasfilm vault so he found old
and archived footage from a new hope for
the duo McGinnis even recorded new
dialogue specifically for rogue one
still it was a gamble Edwards was
skeptical about using the old footage at
first but when the two rebel leaders
appeared on-screen during rogue ones
premiere the audience cheered
[Music]